[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX SALTONSTALL: Today
we're here with Cristina,
CEO and founder of Pandium.
And we're really
excited to explore more
about what Pandium does.
Before we jump
into it, Cristina,
can you tell us, at its
core, what is Pandium doing?
CRISTINA FLASCHEN: Absolutely.
So Pandium is an
integration platform
that makes it easier for
every B2B software company
to have their own
in-app marketplace
and also to be present in the
marketplaces of their larger
partners.
So application integration
is not what it used to be,
and integration is
really about distribution
and reaching your customers
wherever they are,
whether that's within
your own application
or in the marketplace
of your larger partners.
Pandium is an
infrastructure platform
that makes it easier
for software companies
to build and support
those marketplaces.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So
it sounds like Pandium
is helping businesses reach
other businesses pretty
broadly.
Can you tell us a
little bit about some
of those specific companies
and how you've helped them?
CRISTINA FLASCHEN:
Yeah, absolutely.
We work across all
different verticals,
but one of our customers is in
the sports management space.
Their customers are interested
in moving information
about their rosters, their
invoices, their registrations
into all of the other tools
that they use day to day,
whether that's an accounting
software, a CRM, email
marketing, or sports
endemic tools that
are specific to their industry.
We power their
integration marketplace
so that their customers can go
and connect to all of the tools
that they use directly from
within that application.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Pandium's helping
reduce some of the complexity
for them and their developers.
How are you able to make
the developers' lives easier
as they're looking to do all
these third-party integrations?
CRISTINA FLASCHEN: Absolutely.
So we are a SaaS platform, and
we help our engineering users
build integration
scripts in languages
that make sense to
them without having
to deal with a lot of
the operational overhead
of the marketplace itself,
system authentication, logging,
enabling their
customer support team
to help those customers
if they have issues.
We've productized everything
around that exercise
so that the engineers
at our customers
can focus on building
out the business logic
and not focus on all
that infrastructure.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's awesome.
And it sounds like you're
going to make them happier
because they're doing
less of the overhead
and more of the
actual feature design.
CRISTINA FLASCHEN:
That's the goal, yes.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's great.
So can you tell me about some
of the Google technologies
that enabled you
to build Pandium
and how you put it all
together under the hood?
CRISTINA FLASCHEN: We are
an infrastructure product
at our core with
some cool features
and skins on top of it.
And we face a lot
of the same problems
that any developer
platform would face around
authentication,
security, and storage.
We have also the
added complexity
of running third-party code.
So our engineering users
at our customer sites
actually push code
to our platform.
So it was really
important to us to have
an architecture that
allowed us to do this safely
and securely at scale.
It was an obvious
choice for us when
we learned about
Kubernetes to go down
the path of microservices.
It really allows us to partition
our users and our accounts
in a safe way so that if
code is doing something
that we don't need
it to, we don't
have an issue like
a monolithic design
where it could take
down our entire system.
And GCP includes a lot of
the kind of universal tools
that we need to support
Kubernetes at massive scale.
We use Google's key
management service
to manage our authentication
into our accounts.
And we also use GKE, the
managed Kubernetes engine,
to take care of a lot of the
operational and DevOps overhead
so we can focus on
building the platform.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So you've
got a lot of customers each
with their own Kubernetes
clusters and instances.
How do you handle
the operational load
of that growth?
CRISTINA FLASCHEN:
Another great part
of using GKE and GCP is that
we have a great team OF SREs
behind us that can help us.
It's very, very
uncommon that we have
an issue with our
production account
and have to make a
ticket with support.
But if we do, we
know that we're going
to get great support,
better support than we've
gotten when we've used
other providers in the past.
And we have just a massive
team behind us making sure
that all of our clusters
are running well.
That is a resource that
is so valuable to us,
especially being a growing team.
In addition to that,
your docs are amazing.
We really appreciate that the
language in the documentation
is not buzz-wordy.
It makes it a lot easier
for us to talk not only
internally, but also with our
developer users and our product
users about our
technology when there
is common nomenclature that
makes sense for everyone
and isn't specific
to one company.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I'm guessing
you have a lot of repeated work
each time you're
taking on a new client.
Are there ways that
you've found efficiencies
so that you can spin up new
instances of your services
as a new client comes on?
CRISTINA FLASCHEN: Yes.
So Terraform has
been great for us.
And the fact that Google
has templates for Terraform
specifically has made our
deployment process so much more
straightforward.
And again, we're not
reinventing this wheel.
We set this up one time.
We want to focus
on what we do best
and let the folks that
do these things great
continue to do those things
great while we can take
advantage of that technology.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Looking
back on all the things
that you have done, are there
any changes you would make
or big lessons learned
that you want to share?
CRISTINA FLASCHEN: Yes.
So in the very beginning,
we rolled our own Kubernetes
cluster, did all the management
and maintenance ourselves.
I think it was a great learning
experience because we really
got deep into the
guts of Kubernetes.
But when we learned
that GKE was a thing,
it was a very
obvious choice for us
to migrate from another
cloud provider to Google.
And again, it's been
a great experience
not having to worry about a lot
of the operational and DevOps
overhead and just relying
on the excellent support
that we get from Google.
In addition to that,
we would probably
have gone all in on Stackdriver
a little bit earlier.
So we were using GCP
and GKE but tried
to use other monitoring
tools and found
them very cumbersome to set up.
And they weren't really
giving us the deep insights
into the kind of nuts and
bolts of what was happening
in all of our clusters.
We decided to give
Stackdriver a try.
And being a Google product,
it was super easy to implement
and is very closely
tied with GKE.
So we were able to really
get those insights right out
of the box.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
That was really cool.
Thank you very much
for that story.
It was great to hear about
how you built Pandium.
And I appreciate
your collaboration
and your partnership today.
CRISTINA FLASCHEN:
Thank you for having us.
MAX SALTONSTALL: If you'd like
to learn more about Pandium,
visit pandium.com.
Thanks for watching, and
stay tuned for more episodes
of Stack Chat."